so many of you wrote to me and said uh
david you've got to check out this new
interview that jordan peterson did with
joe rogan um i don't know how many of
you have been following but jordan
peterson after i mean i don't even know
that i i feel the need to completely
characterize it but he basically due to
medical
you know we could call the medical
issues addiction issues he dropped off
the public face of the earth for years
and then now he's back and um it might
not shock you guys that in the context
of the kovid pandemic he's sort of on
this um
man it's just the problem the reason i'm
struggling is
the the peterson acolytes
if
no matter what you say if it's even
remotely critical they will say you're
not understanding him because you're not
smart enough so you're misstating what
he stands for he's not exactly been a
fan of any kind of public health
measures
being required
uh maybe i'll just leave it at that he's
sort of like in that in that contingent
he reappeared on the joe rogan program
and has become almost a parody of
himself i mean i'm just going to look at
some clips here and again i know i'm
stepping in i'm stepping on a wasp's
nest here because everybody's going to
write in who loves this guy and say
david
you are so
ignorant that you don't have the
capacity to understand what he's saying
what he's saying does make sense but
i encourage you to prove that to me tell
me that what he says here makes any
sense other than being the exact type of
nothing means anything post-modern
nonsense that he claims to be against
take a look at this hard to sort out the
climate change one is a weird one so
that one that's because there's no such
thing as climate right climate and
everything are the same word
and that's what bothers me about the
climate change types it's like
this is the types people who are like oh
here's the science those types bother
him something that bothers me about it
technically it's like
climate is about everything
it's okay
but your models aren't based on
everything your models are based on
a set number of variables yeah so that
means you've reduced the variables which
are everything
to that set
well how did you decide which set of
variables to include in the equation if
it's about everything
and that's not just a criticism that's
like if it's about everything your
models aren't right
because your models do not and cannot
model everything what do you mean now
what's crazy about this is
when people say climate is about
everything
i mean listen
correct me if i'm wrong but
when we say climate is about everything
what i think of is
um there's these meta issues
in in society right and those meta
issues are
uh you know our economic system
um access to health care
media
and climate and what i mean by that is
if you care about abortion
or you care about net neutrality or you
care about whatever
if
you are unable to even sustain yourself
economically it's hard to be an activist
because you're like where is my next
meal going to come from
if you don't have access to health care
it's hard to be an activist for what
matters to you because
you're sick and you don't have care
and
climate is in that meta-issue
category in that
if we have systemic climate change
that
damages the planet and creates death
from pollution and all these you know
flooding et cetera it's hard to be an
activist for abortion when you're being
forced to relocate because of rising sea
level so
that's a completely reasonable way to
say climate's about everything but what
jordan peterson is saying is nonsense
and people will say i i scroll down
right now on youtube david you aren't
you're you're not understanding the
brilliance of this man all of these
claims are indefeasible anytime it
sounds like he makes no sense you can
say you just don't understand what he's
saying it makes perfect sense um
here's another
clip
where they talk about um i guess this is
about race and how like when you say
someone is white their skin is not
literally white and when you say someone
is black their skin is not literally
black it's like this is a i remember
this conversation in fifth grade in
fifth grade we would say i'm not really
i remember a conversation with the
teacher i'm not really white my skin is
like tan
and two black kids in the class would
say i'm not really black my skin is
brown and we were we were told
that the we're not literally
guys this is two grown men doing this
depending on who you ask either you're a
voice of reason and rationality and
and uh you know uh personal
responsibility or
you're a voice of intolerance and
bigotry and anger and hateful
sexual oppression what did michael
prejudice
yeah and and a mean angry white man
hilarious yeah yeah you're not mean at
all yeah that's what's dumb about that
statement it's you're not mean at all
it's i am white actually that's a lie
too i'm kind of tan
because i'm i'm darker than you yeah
yeah that's ridiculous yeah but neither
of us are white well i'm italian and he
was brown not black wow isn't that weird
yeah it's really weird black and white
thing is so strange because the shades
are shannon brown there's such a
spectrum of shades of people i i had
this conversation when i was 10 with our
teacher i remember every people saying
to the teacher can you explain why we're
called white and there we figured this
out in fifth grade guys people unless
you're talking to someone who is like
100 percent african from the darkest
place where they're not wearing any
clothes all day and they've developed
all that melanin to protect themselves
from the sun
you know even the term black is weird
you're not really black unless you
aren't wearing clothes all day this is
crazy guys this there this there are
people who worship this
um here
decode this one and and i there's people
saying this is brilliant here's peterson
talking about music theory
and i i mean
you just you have to see it seems like a
parody so let's think about what music
is yes
first of all it's it's a pattern so
non-pattern music is noise it's a
pattern but then it isn't one pattern
it's multiple patterns
layered on top of one another
in a harmonious manner
and in a manner that
indicates
in some sense communication between all
the patterned layers because they have
to go together
and so
what's the world
while the world's made of objects it's
like no it's not it's made of patterns
so music is just like the world
because the world's made of patterns
and then music
has layered patterns that are all moving
together in a harmonious manner the the
thing that is frustrating to me about
this
is that
i'm not saying jordan peterson's a dumb
guy
but
there's this thing that happens where
it's very common that with lots of
public intellectuals
the way in which they speak is not
particularly accessible to lots of
people
and uh it starts to be sort of like well
i believe that they're really brilliant
so therefore the fact that i don't
really get this is probably my deficit
and i'm sure that everything they're
saying is great this is an example of
where like some of the stuff he's saying
is kind of uncontroversial
but it's all being tied together in what
truly is
a nonsense word salad
and um it it it doesn't mean that
there's nothing here of substance but
this is not exactly you know the um
the reaction that this clip is getting
as if this is some incredible brilliant
thing
it's it's really not and it has to be
okay for us to say that these are very
strange rantings
and so what do you do when you hear that
especially if it's got a beat
well then you move your body and you
want to right the music calls to you to
move your body so now you're moving your
body in sync with the patterned layers
of the world
that's meaning and then there's more to
so that's so cool is music is an analog
of the structure of existence itself and
it calls to you to take part in that and
then so maybe you dance by yourself or
maybe even better you dance with someone
else and so then you both bring your
bodies into man i mean i just i just
don't hear here's one about protected
classes i think people are going after
this is part of the cultural war stuff
where now you can't joke anymore comedy
for a different thing today because
they're going after comedy for a literal
literal representation of what the words
mean if you put them in print
and that's nonsense yeah that's not what
a comedian yeah well they're doing that
though they're doing that because there
are some things they believe that can't
be made fun of yeah but really what
they're doing is just looking for
targets they're playing a game the game
the rules of the game have been
established comedy violates the rules of
the game yeah what is the comedy take
those things well there's a lot of
things you can't joke about you can't
joke sacred things yeah there's there's
protected classes now we all know what
they are we don't have to bring them up
you know whether it's trans people gay
people people of color and again this is
like the perfect way to make it seem
like oh you know liberals just don't
want anybody to have fun you can't have
fun anymore it's just they don't they
don't want any fun
of course the the real
the the truth about comedy and joking
about things that that are sometimes
seen as sacred the truth is
context and intent
matters when we make jokes about jews or
blacks or gays or whatever
and of course you can find people
who would say you you can never make any
joke ever at the expense of these 10
groups
that's a very small portion of people
and
leftists like me and others understand
context and understand
considering intent and these can be
blurry areas but to make it seem as
though that it's just comet you can't do
comedy anymore it's just not allowed if
you have these things it's just not true
all right here's the last one and here's
jordan peterson explaining
uh
the book the bible versus the idea of
the bible
i know i know
so i just walked through the museum of
the bible in washington that was very
cool it's a very cool museum so the
structure that's what the body yeah
that's what i figured out i mean i just
figured this out this week
so it was a cool
it was a cool thing to walk through
because
it's it's chronological they have one
floor which is the history of the bible
okay it's not exactly that it's really
what it is is the history of the book ah
now in many ways the first book was the
bible i mean literally
because okay so wait a second
the floor is about the history of the
bible but it's not about the history of
the bible it's about the history of the
book
and the first book was the bible okay
at one point there was only one book
right like as far as our western culture
is concerned there was one book and now
are we saying literally one copy or
there was one tome while literally there
was only one book ah okay and that book
was the bible and then before it was the
bible it was a you know scrolls and it
was wait so the book that was the bible
existed before it was a book or it was
existed before it was the bible writings
on papyrus and but it was we were
starting to aggregate written texts
together and it went through all sorts
of technological transformations and
then it became
books that everybody could buy the book
everybody could buy and the first one of
those was the bible so how many books
are there now it became all sorts of
books that everybody could buy
but all those books in some sense
emerged out of that underlying book and
that book itself the bible isn't a book
it's a library oh it's not a book at all
uh guys
okay bring it on guys com come tell me i
don't understand the genius of that come
tell i'm ready for it i'm ready for it
one of our sponsors is kami koto making
elegant high-end beautiful japanese
steel kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from honshu japan i've been a
big fan of japanese kitchen knives for a
long time they have some great
advantages when you look closely at a
kamikoto knife you see the quality of
the iron work they only use japanese
steel every knife comes in a perfect
heavy duty ash wood box makes storage
really easy it looks great in your
kitchen or drawer the balance of the
knives is just amazing i've been using
them for everything every knife comes
with a lifetime guarantee on their
website you can see the complete list of
chefs at michelin star restaurants who
use kamikoto and through this
partnership they're doing with us
kamikoto is giving you fifty dollars off
on top of their other special offers
just go to
camikoto.com
pacman and use the code pacman for fifty
dollars off the link is down below